the jurogan experience well i think
that's because we are both seen as
people who are sort of like
commonsensical
and that is what there is a hunger for i
think in america more than anything is
common sense yes the
away from the extremes i mean when
people say to me you know you're don't
you think you've gotten more
conservative no i haven't the left has
gotten goofier yes so i seem more
conservative maybe but like
it's not me who changed yeah i feel i'm
the same guy but five years ago
uh
you know we hadn't spent six trillion
dollars
to stay home i mean i understand we had
to do something with the pandemic i'm
not sure that was
you know i mean i remember when a
trillion dollars was too much to spend
on anything we didn't spend a trillion
to bail out
the economy in 2008.
um
so we didn't do that five years ago no
one was talking about abolishing
the police
you know there was no talk about uh
you know
pregnant men and you know i mean there
was
looting was still illegal right yeah
you know and they're crazy there was
just there's so like have i changed no
because if someone had said 20 years ago
i i'm not sure looting is a bad thing i
would have opposed it then see i so i
haven't changed
but that i think is what there is this
hunger for is this sort of
common sense you know centrism is such a
wishy-washy word
but
that's sort of what it is something
people lean a little more to the left a
little more to the right sometimes it's
issue by issue
but just
you know i'm always saying to the
democrats just don't be the party of no
common sense and you will be surprised
at how much amazing success you will
have as opposed to what's going to have
happen which is they're going to get
their ass kicked in november
well
people like you are very important to
people like me because you represent
what means what it means to me to be
liberal what it means to me to be
left-wing because you're just a normal
person who cares about people's rights
and wants a certain amount of freedom
and wants the
people to get along and work things out
amicably right
but
the polarization of this country has
made it so that people like you are rare
it's weird it's like that's what i used
to think of when i thought of the left i
thought of like professors and you know
intellectuals and these these people
that would
sit down and work through things with
the understanding that free speech is
like one of the most
important aspects of communication
possible and communication is everything
communication is how we work things out
like this idea of not talking to people
you disagree with well guess what that
just galvanizes them they just get
hardened and they move further and
further away and we get more and more
associated with this idea of left and
right and uh good and bad and one and
zero and this side does not agree with
anything that side says that's crazy it
doesn't make any sense and if you're out
there doing it it gives people hope and
it's not just we're saying common sense
you do have common sense but more
importantly you have courage because
courage allows you to speak your mind
whether you're right or wrong courage
allows you to take a chance and you're
seeing the wave of people that are
moving in a certain direction it doesn't
necessarily make sense and you're like
hey what the [ __ ] is going on and
everybody's like finally someone's
saying it on tv because maybe someone
said it at a cocktail party maybe
someone said it at a barbecue but
they're not [ __ ] saying it on hbo
until you say it on hbo well thank you i
appreciate that i mean that's a lot i
always say you know there's levels of
courage there's like
yeah i mean i will i will take that
compliment
as long as i can also say but there's
like
marines yeah you probably you're not a
navy seal absolutely exactly you're not
even a woman about to give birth i'm in
the d league yeah in the d league i have
a lot of courage but i'm not playing in
the upper league which you have is
honesty but thank you yes you have
honesty
and people know that and that's why your
show works and that's also i always feel
like what my bond with the audience is
you don't have when i started way back
on politically incorrect almost 30 years
ago
people said you know this show will
never work because a tv host
can never reveal his politics i mean
johnny carson never did leno didn't
david letterman you they never said i'm
voting for this guy whereas i mean you
obviously know who all the late-night
hosts are for now right i mean it's a
completely one-sided thing they have to
pander to the liberal audience which is
watches them it's it's so it's so
reverse of when i started it's bonkers
when you couldn't be political and now
you couldn't survive apparently in late
night television unless you are
political unless the audience knows
exactly that you're and i would put
saturday night live in this too it's i
think elon musk uh took them to task he
said it doesn't seem like a show that's
about comet anymore so much is it a it
is about
declaring some woke doctrine yeah um and
you know having people the people who go
to those shows and uh are in there i
guess where they film them and stuff
my audience was was too doctrinated for
a while we
we have a much better audience now
because we kind of got rid of the
growners the people for whom i was
always too politically incorrect and i
was like i've been doing this forever
the names of the shows politically
incorrect real time and you still come
to this show and groan when i say
something too real what [ __ ] show did
you think you were coming to
because they do film the prices right in
the same studio
do you think that the way it's going
right now with late night television
where you you everyone has to be
political is that what the audience
wants or is that what the executives in
the studio wants are they like who is
are they one step behind
like what where where is the the mandate
coming from is it the person who's the
host who says you know what i know works
in this town if i want to keep working i
have to be like outwardly left-leaning
progressive political look it's i think
it's coming from both because
corporations in america now
um are they're leaning in
they're leaning into woke
hardcore they're they're petrified of
some kind of backlash i mean you see
with disney now i mean disney one of the
most gay-friendly
companies
that we've had in a very long time
as they should be old companies should
be gay friendly but disney sort of they
had gay days yeah at disney what is it
world land i don't know i'm not at
disney i think it was the la one right
you'll never find land
disneyland is the original that's right
disney world is in florida right you'll
never find me sitting in a tea cup joe
i love teacups
i mean
it says in my category of things that
only children used to do that now adults
do i mean if i had a nickel for every
time somebody said you know i'm going to
disneyland and i'm like with your kids
no we're just going
okay
but
you know there is that there is
corporations i think yes are always
going to want to and look i'm glad they
are progressive thinking of course like
with everything on the left these days
they just take it too far but i think
it's coming from the audience more
because the audience
who goes to a taping of saturday night
live or a show like that they're
youngish
and you know they
um
they believe what they believe a lot of
the things i also
believe uh but it's it's sort of an
unexamined like
they don't know too much about politics
they just know
that and again you mentioned trump doing
this like he was so awful that it's just
very easy to turn off to the details and
go well i'm with the democrats in the
left